the major problem with with
transportation technology and
transportation policy is that you have a
battle between utopians who believe that
they can get whatever they want faster
better cheaper and the pragmatists The
Hardball economic types who say no no no
no no let's ban the car from the city
let's create calming zones of
zero-emission vehicles etc etc you have
a real dialectic real tension and my
view is when you have that kind of
schizophrenia when you have that kind of
chasm not just of technologies and
expectations but the values I think you
get into a lot of gridlock pun intended
there's so many things going on that are
so exciting that it's not clear to me
what's the best bet we have smart
vehicles smart devices smarter people
better sensors more information the
ability to have the technology act in a
more nimble way we even have the ability
to play with tax policy and the end
congestion charges so to me the question
is going to be there's a tension between
disruptive innovation and rapid
iterative incremental innovation but if
you have enough incremental innovation
in a short period of time he got a
revolution you know the simple model for
that is like a mapquest or putting an
accelerometer in an iphone the fact of
the matter is between mobile phones
between iphones between rims between gps
every car in the world every bicycle in
the world can be made smarter heck we
can make every street corner every
street lamp smarter more nimble more
agile the issue is what's the organizing
principle underlying that having a clue
being an MIT /
I'm very very sympathetic to that view
of G let's just start from scratch let's
reinvent everything but basically I
think it's a bunch of crap you know
that's basically like saying gee we've
sequenced the human genome let's rien je
r human being so they'll make less
they'll take up less space they'll
they'll do less waste and be more energy
efficient it's rubbish as I said earlier
there's always going to be a tension
between the incremental and the
revolutionary folks at MIT tend to
self-select towards the revolutionary
side but ordinary human beings typical
human beings human beings who have shall
we say real lives not MIT lives are more
prepared to have a mix of the disruptive
innovation and the incremental
innovation and that's how I think that's
going to play out particularly in
transportation policy I don't believe
people are going to give up on the
wheels of a car for the foreseeable
future
I don't know frankly i don't care if
there's an internal combustion engine in
a car a fuel cell in a car a battery
integral i don't care my friends who are
incredibly green care a lot now do i
think they've actually done the math and
calculated the carbon footprint of fuel
cells versus batteries versus internal
combustion engines throughout the entire
supply and value chain heck no and i
think that's where we're going to see a
lot of the policy battles because
they're all manner of ways of allocating
costs and responsibilities for the the
carbon footprint of an automobile for
the carbon footprint of a person or
should we say the carbon pirate track
we will always have congestion problems
the issue is what's tolerable if you had
told me that that I would be on a
40-minute commute I would say you're
crazy but I've gotten adjusted to it by
the way let's let's deal with that as an
example 25 years ago being stuck in
traffic was a horrible horrible waste of
time if you got a mobile phone if you if
your kids are watching TV in the
backseat it's not so bad it's not so bad
now what transportation planner
anticipated the impact of mobile phones
in the car and TV screens lcds in the
backseat none of them none of them and
heck I've read a lot of science fiction
I didn't see those scenarios being
played out by Isah kazem over Harlan
Ellison either